checkmate you know would probably help
if we actually know how to play the game
yeah probably man if only there were
like a video game that combines halo and
strategy together what about Halo Wars I
reviewed it we're doing the video for it
this week oh yeah right oh maybe you
could like teach us like five hot tips
how to play halo wars I can do that yeah
Wow huh ok cool uh double plasma rifles
drink number one building your
foundation you'll want to build at least
two marine supply pads or covering the
warehouses right off the bat because you
can't really filled an army if your bro
next you'll want to build a reactor or a
covenant temple this will allow you to
upgrade your Buena and your bases
stronger units live longer and prosper
number to bury your troops it's kind of
like rock-paper-scissors vehicles beat
infantry infantry be aircraft and
aircraft beat vehicles but some units
don't play by the rules and you never
really know what your enemy is going to
throw at you make sure you have a varied
squad so you always have the right
troops for the job number three don't
forget about your special abilities
squads and commanders have special
abilities that can turn the tide of a
battle here's an example your puny
grunts are about to get steamrolled by a
bunch of tanks hit the Y button and
they'll toss a few grenades which just
might save their lives if things start
really get tricky can always call in
death from above for a price number four
know your enemy but also know yourself
study your armies strengths and
weaknesses the Covenant have shields but
their units are generally a bit weaker
the Marines are tougher but they're much
harder to heal the smart commander knows
went to fight and went to run and hide
number five don't get overconfident
steamrolling your enemy with a horde of
tanks pretty awesome and expensive one
air strike later and you're suddenly
broke in toothless even if it looks like
you're about to win never stop capturing
new basis so you'll always have
resources to spend and a place to fall
back to
you